Коли ми тільки приїхали, був випадок у брата
Він пішов у перукарню
Перукарка його стриже й питає: «Хто Ви за національністю?»
Він каже: «Вгадайте», й вона починає
– Азербайджанець? Вірменин? Грузин?
– Ні
– А хто?
– Турок
– Дівчата, дівчата, тут живий турок з'явився!
Всім було цікаво, як екзотика
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Виноградівка,
Причорномор'я]
Ми зараз їдемо в село Костичі
Там ми зараз принесемо в жертву двох бичків
[Марат Расулов
голова Всеукраїнського товариства месхетинських турків «Ватан»]
Тут у нас пошта
Тут колись був клуб
Ми в молодості туди ходили в кіно, на дискотеки
А зараз уже розвалився
Тут гуртожиток, в який поселили всіх,
хто в перші дні, коли нас...
Ми сюди приїхали
Спочатку ми тут 3-4 місяці жили
І в перші дні люди нам
приносили продукти:
молоко, сир, яйця.
Ми це, звісно, ніколи не забудемо
Завжди будемо вдячні українському
народові за те, що нас
підтримав в складний для нас час
[турецькою]
Щасливих свят!
Зі святом!
Проходьте, пригощайтеся!
[турецькою]
Проходь, всередині вдягнеш
Йди сюди, йди
Проходьте, проходьте. Зі святом вас.
Заходьте, проходьте далі
Діти так приходять, святкують,
суто символічно беруть зі столу
кілька цукерок,
щоб не образити господарів
І також уявіть собі,
якщо у кожному домі будеш
так довго сидіти і їсти,
то й не влізе
Із цих міркувань, так, суто
декілька, так сказати,
шматків кавуна, винограда
або ще чогось легенького беруть
Тому що покарання — для шлунку і справді складнувато
[турецькою]
Налий ще одну склянку
Це свято
втілює в собі повне поклоніння Богу,
яке триває з часів Авраама,
або ж Ібрагіма
він мав принести в жертву свого сина,
і він дав слово — стримав слово
Тут сенс не в тому, що...
Богу ні м'ясо, ні шкура овеча не потрібна —
йому потрібне саме поклоніння
Що ми поклоняємося і підпорядковуємося його вимогам
[турецькою]
– Як ти?
– Ласкаво просимо!
[турецькою]
Все гаразд, дякувати Богу
Зі святом!
Показуй!
[турецькою]
Вони зовсім не схожі
А ці хіба схожі? Ця чорнява, ця білява.
І волосся різне
[турецькою]
— Як справи?
— Добре
Молодші ходять до старших
Сьогодні вранці хлопці прийшли,
потім дівчата — окремо
У мусульман два основних свята —
це Рамазан Байрам і Курбан-Байрам.
Це — жертвоприношення
Пам'ятаю, змалечку
ми ходили з такими шампурами
по дворах, де ріжуть...
І в кожному дворі нам давали шматок м'яса
От ми забирали цей шматок
і десь там на полі шашлики готували
[Пашалі Султанов
співзасновник Всеукраїнського товариства месхетинських турків «Ватан»]
І сьогодні протягом дня, тепер — після обіду,
от сьогодні, завтра, післязавтра
в пакетах нестимуть
найближчі родичі по кілограму, по два
А так, усім поспіль будуть у відрах,
в пакетиках розносити
по 200-300 грам м'яса, то вже як вийде
І всім розносять, щоб цей день святкували всі
[турецькою]
Хай Аллах прийме
Дякую, хай благословить тебе Аллах
[турецькою]
Щасливих свят!
Дякую!
[турецькою]
Зі святом!
Дякую, дорогенька, і вас зі святом
[турецькою]
Сама робила?
Я зробила, а хто ще зробить?
[турецькою]
Наче й вона теж допомагала
Я кажу, ви робіть торт,  ваші гарні, щоб я не пекла
[турецькою]
Так, ми також обрізали, і от знову розцвіли
Бутони?
[турецькою]
І у вас білі?
Ні.
Увесь день столи у всіх вдома накриті,
тому що у будь-який момент
можуть прийти гості
Тут в селі всі намагаються один одного привітати
Якщо хтось сьогодні не встиг, то він піде завтра
Вітають зі святом,
бажають один одному благополуччя,
і щоб наступного року у цей час
всі були живі здорові, дожили до цих днів
і наступного року знову це свято відзначали
«Салам алейкум» у перекладі з арабської — «мир над вами»
Співрозмовник відповідає: «Алейкум а салам» – навзаєм
[турецькою]
Виходьте, сину. Виходь
Тримай пакети за ручки, добре?
У нас в релігії таке:
обов'язково, якщо ти зарізав здобич,
то треба роздавати в Курбан-байрам
[турецькою]
Хай Аллах прийме
Дякую
[турецькою]
Гарного дня
Аллаху акбар
[моляться]
На вулиці смачніше, ніж вдома
[Рафіка Расулова
туркеня-масхетинка]
Все таки, на дровах смачніше
[турецькою]
Вже є світло, Марат?
Зараз закинемо і тебе в казан
Оскільки ми 45 років прожили в Середній Азії,
багато хто готує плов
До того ж, є і інші національні страви
Є грузинські хінкалі
Ми їх теж називаємо «хінкалі», але,
наприклад, грузинські хінкалі у нас — «інкал».
Наші трішки менші, ніж грузинські,
і потім...
У нас парові манти
теж готують.
Хтось пиріжки готує.
Ну, загалом...
Змішувалися корені, люди,
різниці немає
А вазагалі, інколи
приходять,
навіть не відрізнити — турок чи українець
Тому що тут з такою засмагою і українці трапляються,
що можна переплутати
Ну а так, люди, всі люди — однакові, жодної різниці
Є просто хороша людина і погана людина
За рахунок того, що ми компактно живемо,
ми змогли зберегти свою мову, звичаї, традиції
От товариш з Туреччини приїхав і дивується:
«Ніби до себе в село приїхав»
Каже: «Усі ті ж традиції. Ви нічого не втратили»
Оскільки ми — турки, то для нас
велика батьківщина — це Туреччина
Але ми живемо в Україні
Ми є патріотами
Для нас це — теж друга батьківщина
Ви знаєте, особисто я нікуди не хочу поїхати
Якщо я в Туреччину поїду, мене що, на халяву годуватимуть там?
Всюди треба працювати
[Месхетинські турки — тюркомовний народ, який сповідує іслам]
[та походить з Месетії — історичної території на межі Грузії та Туреччини.]
[У 1944 році радянська влада виселила їх в Середню Азію]
[звідки вже у 90-х роках вони тікали через міжетнічний конфлікт]
[Спільнота месхетинських турків мешкає в Україні з 90-х років ХХст.]
[Розселилися вони переважно на Причорномор'ї, Таврії, Слобожанщині та Бессарабії]
[Вони плекають свої традиції і щорічно відзначають релігійні свята]
[серед яких — Курбан-байрам]
[Автор проекту: Богдан Логвиненко
Продюсерка: Ольга Шор]
[Режисер: Микола Носок
Оператори: Марія Теребус, Микола Носок, Олександр Хоменко]
[Режисерка монтажу: Марія Теребус
Звукорежисер: Павло Пашко]
[Субтитрувальниці:
Валерія Діденко, Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]